Courage is an external thing.
So I have met people who literally have courage.
What we would call courage.
They have put their lives on the line,
they have thrown themselves into harms way
in order to save the life of someone else.
They have done something that we would consider mad,
that violates all tenets of survival ...
so that someone else will survive.
Courage.
Real courage.
And I've talked to them and I always say,
"Why did you do it?"
You've got a wife, you've got kids.
Why would you do that?
And they all give me the same answer.
Every time.
"Because they would have done it for me."
"Because someone else would have done the same
for me."
It is the absolute confidence
that the person to the left and
the person to the right
would do the same for me
that gives them the courage
to do amazing things.